today we're going to talk about a rather
serious topic
the future
[Applause]
[Music]
hello again and welcome back this is hof
here with pop lock northern colorado and
the auto pro pad g2 turbo
today we are in the back seat tee of a
dodge charger we've already got our
dc 2011 cable plugged in
we have a obd extension in order to make
it so we can reach back here get power
to the bci
which is lost keys and let's see if i
can
fit in here
again this is the 2020 charger this is
not one that has had the
rfh hub locked so we can still
communicate with it and program new keys
we are plugged in
security code
i am online
three six two seven two okay
i'm gonna erase smart keys
and now add smart key
hazards are on
secure entry failed try again
all right just second try took it
so
all right so it took it
programming success
number of keys
one key 2020 dodge charger lost keys
[Music]